look at the fraction two by three all
fractions have a very special property
if we multiply the numerator and the
denominator of a fraction by the same
number the value of the fraction remains
unchanged let's say we multiply the
numerator and the denominator by two
two times two is four and three times
two is six
so this will equal four by six these two
fractions have the same value or we can
also multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 3 to get six by nine all
these three fractions will have the same
value if we multiplied the numerator and
the denominator by the same value the
fractions value remains unchanged now by
intuition we should also derive another
special property of fractions what do we
get if we divide 6 and 9 by 3 yes 2 by 3
it tells us that even if we divide the
numerator and the denominator by the
same value the fraction remains
unchanged let's look at an example
consider the fraction 12 by 18 we can
divide the numerator as well as the
denominator by 6 the numerator will be
12 by 6 and the denominator will be 18
by 6 12 by 6 is 2 and 18 by 6 is 3 12 by
18 and 2 by 3 are the same and this 2 by
3 here is called the simplest form it
means that this fraction cannot be
reduced further that's cool but how did
we know what number we are supposed to
divide them by the number 6 is in fact
the highest common factor of the
numerator and the denominator if we
divide the numerator as well as the
denominator by their HCF we get the
simplest form
say we have a fraction 30 by 50 and
let's assume that you do not know what
their HC F is if we do not know the HC f
all we need to do is look at the common
factors of the numerator and the
denominator 30 as well as 50 are
divisible by 2 so we divide the
numerator as well as the denominator by
2 30 divided by 2 is 15 and 50 divided
by 2 is 25 if there are no common
factors of the numerator and the
denominator it means that the answer is
in the standard form but 15 and 25 both
have 5 as that common factor which tells
us that this is not the simplest form we
divide the numerator as well as the
denominator by 5 15 divided by 5 is 3
and 25 divided by 5 is 5 the numbers 3 &
5 do not have any common factors apart
from 1 so this is the simplest form or
the standard form of the fraction 30 by
50 the product of the numbers we divided
the numerators and denominators by will
be their HCF here 2 times 5 which equals
10 is the HCF of 30 and 50 it is always
recommended that you first find the HCF
and then divide the numerator and the
denominator by 8 just once instead of
performing division many times this is
also called the simplification of
fractions as we are simplifying it to
its simplest form
you